so this is pretty much like the comedy  workshop we do on zoom but it's gonna be  in person and we're gonna do a show in  four days we must do our exercises  you're gonna go through the curtain and  you're gonna grab this microphone  want to thank you all for coming to my  bar mitzvah  the man goes to the doctor and the  doctor says you know you have to stop  masturbating because why  because i'm trying to examine you  thank you all for being here has anyone  been to a 2pm comedy show before  oh my god my wife left me recently  she's so naughty  life is a performance then there was my  head surgery  my boss ever sees this i'm dead  the actor it's like food you put in your  body i would like to uh be funny but not  in an artificial way you know genuinely  i think that you are genuinely funny you  do yeah really yes you're the first  person that's ever told you  [Applause]  [Music]  you